[Applaudissements]
oubliée alors bérengère vous allez me
dire si je me trompe
un moment il y avait le ticket de métro
maintenant c'est ce qu'on appelle la
titeuf battitta c'est la petite mèche
comme ça s'est su si cyril qui joue dur
et les éditions c'est un accident c'est
une bêtise j'ai lu ça dans un magasin
vous allure et celles à titeuf
j'vous l'dit l'artisanat proviendrait
forme c'est une petite mèche qui vient
d'ici à là et c'est magnifique
non mais je vous le dis fans et la
journée 9 des élections seront pas oui
bien sûr on peut le faire on peut faire
un lissage mecs brésilien nous vous
normalement là mais je vous l'avais déjà
n a plus qu à l'allumer double mais non
merci matthieu delormeau non mais voilà
où est ce qu'on vous des piles et vous
est-ce que vous êtes métrosexuels sous
les branches sont les bains peu mais je
rêve ou débroussailler j'aime pas les
bras s'agissant du cas banon vous ont lu
goût non mais vous vous avez le poil ce
qu'on appelle le poil velcro non lui il
est pile il a le poil est pas exactement
ce que c'est pratique mais auxerre c'est
vrai je voulais passer si je laissais
poussé je ressemblerais fu manchu non
mais c'est le traître asiatiques
il a des poils l'on sait pas où ça vient
en ami un petit polar bipolaire
du vent oui c'est ça mathieu tormo vous
vous êtes et pilote également je vous ai
vu banon mais j'ai totalement imberbe
ah oui même de quoi ah oui oui on
voulait pas le savoir je crois qu'il est
dans quatre autres je crois qu'il est
temps de passer